calibre is a 2018 Scottish thriller
starring Jack Loudon Tony Curran and
Martin McCann the film follows two
friends named Marcus and Vaughn as they
embark on a hunting trip in the Scottish
Highlands after an initial mishap during
the trip the GOL find themselves an
increase in danger as natives to the
village slowly begin to attack and
threaten them throughout this video I
will be discussing the film's plot and
ending so there will be heavy spoilers I
definitely think that this film is worth
your time with no prior knowledge and
highly recommend that you go in as blind
as possible you have been warned with
that out the way I'm definition and this
is my ending explanation for calibre
during a hunting trip Vaughn
accidentally shoots a child wounding
them fatally when rushing to the body
Bourne is met by the child's father who
angry at what has happened aims a gun at
the protagonist Vaughn's friend Marcus
saves his life shooting the father and
we can conclude that he came to this
decision due to the fact that his
previous interactions with the villagers
have been almost violent and there was
definitely an uneasy tension to every
interaction with them deciding that they
have to cover up the crime the duo
agreed to return an eye and under the
cover of darkness buried the bodies back
in the village
the group from Pender Logan who is one
of the villages head citizens I loved
their tense interaction in the
restaurant and we see that Bourne
struggles to eat venison this venison
reminds him of the hunting trip
and it was a nice callback that
signifies just how guilty Bourne feels
returning at night they bury the bodies
however they're planned soon and Phil's
and the villagers discover the corpses
and due to the strange actions of Bourne
and Marcus realise what has happened the
majority of the villagers want to kill
the pair however Logan dissuades them
knowing that they're already financially
unstable village will come under more
stress should the majority of its
keynote figures be reprimanded by the
police debating with the rest of the
villagers through the night Logan comes
up with a plan to make them even and
this results in Bourne being forced to
shoot Marcus Logan's brother one of the
main antagonists I wanted
to pay stated earlier in the standoff
that it should be an eye for an eye and
it's clear that Logan used this to find
a way for Vaughn to make it out of the
village alive in his hotel room
Vaughn agrees with Logan that they will
lie about what happened and make it look
like Marcus went off into the woods by
himself
sometime later we returned to see Warren
in his home unable to sleep and dogging
on his baby something that was used to
push him to kill Marcus we see that even
though all he wanted to do was return
home and get to be with his child the
choice that he made has left a huge
impact and he realizes that the life he
has taken has also destroyed his own
borne never wanted to kill we could even
see that he stumbled when firing upon
the air however this decision led him
down a dark path that would have never
happened had he not found joy in taking
another's life now the wicked desire
that he possessed has come back in a car
Mayock way to strip him of his soul and
the film definitely leaves audiences to
think about how all life is precious and
in murdering one thing we kill ourselves
in other ways when watching calibre I
was hit with the realization that Bourne
and Marcus were in fact the villains of
the piece they show up to the rather
peaceful village and caused havoc
changing it in irreversible ways
Marcus is a drug addict that puts his
addiction on others and Bourne comes
close to cheating on his heavily
pregnant fiancee after killing the child
and his father both would rather cover
it up and flee from the scene leaving
the victims families unaware of the fate
that befell them they are completely
beset on escaping and prepared to kill
one another in order to get their goals
a true friend of Marcus would have
refused to murder him but Bourne
participates in the killing due to his
selfish desires the true hero of the
piece is Logan throughout he does his
best to be as humane as possible and
treats the two with kindness and
compassion even after learning of their
wicked deeds whilst it might be better
to contemplate put yourselves in the
village's shoes you would be as angry
and probably want to kill them too and
this is what elevates the film and makes
it so relatable it was easy to put
myself in their shoes and see why they
made the decisions they
did in the end the villagers win because
they get away with the murder of Marcus
and borns life is shattered so in a way
the film has got a happy and I can't
even say that it left me clinically
depressed and I just need a hug so what
did you think of calibre do you agree
with my thoughts on the film or do you
think that Bourne didn't deserve what he
got comment below and let me know and if
you liked this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel as I create
ending explained videos weekly and I'll
definitely be something on here that you
love if you're a fan of film make sure
you check out my breakdown of Netflix's
other film released this week Tao which
will be linked at the end again thanks
very much for taking the time to watch
this and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
[Music]